Maksim Chmerkovskiy kept his engagement
to fellow dancing with the star pro Peta
Murgatroyd so top secret even his
brother Val wasn't in on the surprise
proposal days after max popped the
question to PETA et caught up with the
newly engaged star to get all of her
wedding details
Alison yes well you win on that proposal
no I was not you were totally surprised
no I found out literally like half an
hour before he did that so there an
intermission of all of our show he uh
he was like started show me the ring and
I bummed out yeah you know we love Peter
all jokes aside I loved her honestly
with all my heart and she's been part of
the family for a long time and I'm just
glad that that was official food from
Dancing with the Stars family to in-laws
PETA now has some work to do to make
sure Val finds the woman of his dreams
you know they're putting a lot of
pressure on me especially my mom my mom
has been like well it's your turn out
but Val isn't sure he's ready to let her
play matchmaker said he tried this no as
the matchmaker
I mean I've we've been discussing a few
things yeah what's it come on
yeah yeah I have you two suggestions how
do they go over I have never been hooked
up with somebody and in working out and
I'm really not let's know that that
whole like blind date like friend of a
friend never works out and then I
stopped being friends with a friend so
it's always over it